نحن الان على ضفاف مضيق البسفور في مدينه
اسطنبول في هذه الاثناء يمكننا القول بان
سفن الانقاذ التركيه نجحت في سحب السفينه
سفينه التي جمعت صباح اليوم على الضفه
الاسيويه من مضيق البسفور وادت الى اغلاق
هذا المضيق هذا الممر العالمي مجرى هو انه
في حوالي الساعه السابعه والنصف صباحا من
في التوقيت المحلي
اصيبت هذه السفينه اصيبه موجه الحركه في
هذه السفينه بعطل مما ادى الى جنوعها نحو
الضفه الاسيويه من مضيق البسفور وهو ما
ادى الى اغلاق حركه المرور عبر هذا المضيق
الان نجحت السفن في سحبها الى وسط المضيق
حيث عمق المياه اكبر وبالتالي يمكن لهذه
السفينه ان تعود للحركه متجهه الى هدافها
الاساسي هذه السفينه كانت قادمه من احد
موانئ اوكرانيا وفقا لاتفاقيه نقل الحبوب
هذه الاتفاقيه التي وقعت في تموز يوليو
الماضي
الدفاع كانت قد تمكنت هذه السفن من نقل
اكثر من 17 مليون طن من المواد الغذائيه
والحبوب من اوكرانيا الى مختلف دول العالم
عبر هذا المضيق مضيق البسفور الذي يعتبر
من الممرات المزدحمه عالميا اكثر من
50,000 سفينه تمر في هذا المضيق سنويا
سواء من السفن المحليه او السفن العالميه
التي تاتي من البحر الاسود نحو بحر مرمى
ومنها الى بحر ايجا الى البحر المتوسط
والى مختلف دول العالم وبالتالي الان
يمكننا القول بان السفينه بدات تتحرك
ابتدا ابتعدت عن الضفه وستتكمل طريقها بعد
قليل امرنا في الجزيره اسطنبول